[موسيقى]
المدينه المنكوبه بالكامل يعني البنايه
التي لم تقع على الارض وتنهار مالت او
تشققت يعني هي يعني مساله انهيار هذه
البنايات المائله او المشققه مساله وقت
كما تشاهدون يعني دمار كبير في كل المواقع
واحياء بالكامل ازيلت او سقطت وبالتالي
نتحدث عن حجم دمار كبير جدا
[موسيقى]
وزلزال ليس بالعين المجرده هو زلزال عصفه
بالمدينه بامها وبابيها بكل احيائها ليس
لا يوجد فيها حي الا وقد اكله الزلزال من
اوله الى اخره
[موسيقى]
فكره من الصعب جدا وصف المعاناه والدمار
الذين شهدتهما هنا في حلب الطقس بارد جدا
ولا توجد تدفئه قلبي ينفطر على كل من فقد
احبائه والاباء الذين فقدوا اطفالهم
والاطفال الذين فقدوا ذويهم من الصعب رؤيه
معاناه الاطفال وكبار السن بشكل خاص
[موسيقى]